good evening thank you for joining us
i'm denise valdez
a devastating night for southern nevada
as we grieve the life of nhp trooper
micah may he was hit by a car during a
suspect chase on i-15 on tuesday
and had been in critical condition at
umc ever since that's where sasha loptis
joins us now live tonight with more
about trooper may's life and service in
las vegas
sasha
denise hearts are heavy here at umc
tonight and really all across southern
nevada we've seen members of all
different law enforcement agencies come
and go here tonight
to pay their respects and honor trooper
may for his dedication to our community
after so much uncertainty and sadness
nevada highway patrol has lost one of
its own
trooper micah may died thursday days
after he was hit here
along the i-15
the 46-year-old was placing stop sticks
on the road
during a chase with carjacking suspect
douglas claiborne
a tragic situation like this with a
family going
through what they're going through it's
everything this is a family that's going
to need some help
nhp spoke with 8 news now when trooper
may was still fighting to survive
circumstances have changed but the
message stays the same
his wife and children need support from
those in law enforcement
and our entire community this is a city
where we all come together
and we work well together and we're all
brothers and sisters even though we work
for different agencies
now as those who knew trooper may grieve
his death
they can remember his 13 years of
service
it's these tragic situations like this
where you really realize that
las vegas is a community and it's a
community that cares
and count on our city to come together
to honor this man's courage and heroism
you can see the nevada department of
transportation changed its highway signs
earlier tonight to remember trooper may
this was near i-15
and hacienda he was honored for his
heroic service
with the department receiving the medal
of valor back in 2014.
trooper may has survived by his wife and
two children if you would like to help
them we have a link on how to do that
that's on our website 8newsnow.com
reporting live at umc tonight sasha
loftis
8 news now governor sissel act releasing
a statement tonight which reads in part
micah passed away while bravely
protecting his community
and while he has reached his end of
watch his heroic actions and
contributions to the state of nevada
will never
be forgotten the governor went on to
extend condolences to trooper may and
his family
and from metro tonight our hearts are
broken and we're simply devastated
we groove we grieve with our brothers
and sisters from nevada highway patrol
along with trooper micah may's family
and friends
rest easy sir